[Music]
receiving this award is an incredible
honor
dr king continues to be a source of
inspiration for anybody who believes in
social justice no matter where in the
world they are fighting for it
she's been one of those
faculty members that the students really
can
feel like they're connected with her and
after they graduate sometimes they need
a recommendation letter and a lot of the
times newma is one of the recommend the
person that is writing that for them
because they feel like she got to know
them
[Music]
exactly two years ago one of my students
told me that she was very happy to be in
my class
especially because
it's gonna be the first time i have a
black professor
she was a senior
in her last semester
i know everybody is aware of the need
for more representation
but
we need more than that
we need representation
that has the power
and the will to produce change
in my practice as an educator
i always keep all of this in mind i try
to encourage my students in addition to
learning the language and about the
culture to reflect on their own
histories and cultures
for 12 years we've gathered at least
once a month as a family to share some
food but also to nourish racial souls
speaking the language is
just a pretext to disconnect from
academics share experience news worries
listening to each other
showing empathy taking care of each
other
we try to
maintain our bond and convey that
they
really matter
not only as
members of a class but as individuals
with feelings
dreams
and needs
they belong to this community
thank you
[Music]
you